The Famine Early Warning System started in 1985,
and it was started as a consequence of the
massive loss of life—over a million people—
due to drought-related famine in Sahel, Ethiopia,
and other areas of East Africa.
The idea was to make sure that nothing like that would
ever happen again.
The Famine Early Warning System Network, also
known as FEWS NET,
helps the U.S. Agency for International Development
plan its food aid and relief efforts.
It combines satellite and on-the-ground data
to predict droughts months in advance.
There was not a lot of work that really looked
at a rigorous way at how to combine those
two sources of information in the best way.
That's been one of the things that I’ve specialized in.
There has been a number of initiatives which
allow for the increase in the number of
rain gauges available.
The satellite data really hinges on the rain gauge data
for its calibration.
We now have product called the Climate Hazards
Groups InfraRed Precipitation with Stations, or CHIRPS,
which combines observations from satellites
and gauges to produce what’s probably the
best rainfall product for drought early warning.
CHIRPS was deployed in early 2015,
just in time to monitor worsening conditions of drought
in Ethiopia.
The CHIRPS dataset was in many ways designed from
the get-go to deal with rainfall in Ethiopia because it’s
a really challenging place to try to track
rainfall variations. It's incredibly mountainous,
and those mountains have a huge impact
on the rainfall, where you can go from really
wet highlands to super-hot dry lowlands in
maybe 50 kilometers.
Over the years, FEWS NET has improved its
ability to predict climate patterns, like
the El Niño-Southern Oscillation, where sea-
surface temperatures shift every few years
in the equatorial Pacific Ocean.
The shifts
lead to weather changes all over the world—
even as far away as Africa.
It was forecast to be one of the strongest
El Niños on record.
In Southern Africa, the El Niño Southern Oscillation
tends to have that correlation between El Niño and
below normal rainfall.
The drought in Ethiopia in 2015 was very similar
to the drought in 1984 that helped kill a
million people.
The outcome of the 2015 drought was very different
than 1984: early warnings led to increased
food aid, helping the nation avoid many deaths.
But human induced global warming will worsen
droughts and storms, which means that the
specter of drought—and famine—isn’t going away.
You have in mind that in the background the
odds have been tilted in one direction or
another because of climate change, then that helps
increase confidence in the outlooks that are produced
We should be expecting more of these extreme
events, these really strong El Niño and La Niña events.
In the last five years we’ve had this sequence
of droughts, which have had an increasingly negative
impact on households, simply because of the reduction
in the coping capacity.
If this happens again, and we’re in this situation
where we’re grappling with a post-COVID reality,
I’m worried about in the future if we have reduced
economic capacity, that a super El Niño like event
happens again, it could have really dire consequences.
Our scope now is to always be able to work globally,
and be able to respond wherever we’re
going to be needed in the future.